تحديات كثيره فرضتها اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
والتي تنذر بمنافسه شرسه عنوانها الصداره
للاذكى الصناعيه فمع دخولي هذه الاسلحه في
سباق التسلح بين بكين و واشنطن والذي احدث
نقله نوعيه في الاستراتيجيه الحربيه
الصينيه على المستوى التكتيكي والعسكري
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه الجارديان عن قلق
امريكي من ان تستخدم بكين هذه التقنيه في
السعي وراء السلطه لتحل محل الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها القوه العظمى للذكاء
الاصطناعي في العالم من خلال اسلحه تقنيه
يمكن الاعتماد عليها في الحروب المستقبليه
فالجيش الصيني يسعى لتعميم مفاهيم حرب
الالات الذكيه او حرب الروبوتات المقاتله
المؤهله لتنفيذ العديد من العمليات
العسكريه من خلال روبوتات ومعد صغيره
مجهزه بمدافع رشاشه ونظم رؤيه ليليه
وصواريخ واجهزه استشعار للقيام بالعديد من
المهمات في الخطوط الاماميه وفقا لمعظم
المقاييس التي تعتمد عليها مؤسسه السياسه
الخارجيه في واشنطن فان احتمال وصول الصين
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي العام قبل الولايات
المتحده يبدو وكانه تهديد وجودي للهيمنه
الامريكيه فالتحركات الصين التي تسعى
لتكون مركزا للابتكار في مجال اسلحه
الذكاء الاصطناعي بحلول 2030 يمكن ان تؤدي
الى سباق تسلح جديد تغذيه الاجيال القديمه
من التكنولوجيا وسط مخاوف تتعلق بالخيارات
السريعه التي تتخذها الاسلحه الذكيه من
دون تدخل بشري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات